nicht immer für alles schieben wir
deutschen oder in deutschland ja früher
viel gemacht genau zum beispiel erstmal
welt
[Musik]
jetzt gibt es ja 100 tage den
freiwilligendienst aber jetzt muss bei
einer 100 tagen sagen es sind eigentlich
mehr tage als freiwillige die sich
gemeldet haben oder nicht es werden noch
mal weniger was macht al qaida besser
als die bundestag weil da da ist ja
wirklich die begeisterung einfach da
sind leute da und da kann man nicht so
einfach austreten weil wir da austritt
dann was sie besser machen das weiß ich
nicht ich weiß man davon besser oder
schlechter reden oder sind leute die
kämpfen aber also die sind bereit zu
sterben ja ja ja gut da haben sie auch
den familien bünde wo sechs sieben leute
in der familie gibt dann ist auch die
einstellung auch andere da sagt man wenn
man einen für die ehre verliert aber ich
noch sechs andere kinder das ist nicht
also das heißt wir müssen uns um mehr
nachwuchs sorgen eigentlich finde das
sollte das modell zu übernehmen
das sollte man nie
ok womit kann man schießen ja nicht
schaden
über dem wasser passt ihr ein bisschen
auf neue schuhe
würde es vielleicht helfen wenn die
soldaten die einsatz länder selber
auswählen dürfen ich denke an die
schönen strände von thailand zum
beispiel also jetzt nicht in dieser
länder ein wo es halt sehr schlimm ist
oder so der eben und deswegen wäre die
idee zu sorgen
suchen welches land halt gern möchten
genau so kommen zeit attraktiver machen
die leute dass du bist natürlich man
müsste den thailändern dann eigentlich
hat den krieg erklären damit man
überhaupt hin kommt das ist dann
natürlich wieder ärgerlich aber
irgendwas ist immer
hier sind immer ein paar vorschläge wie
man die bundeswehr attraktiver slogans
hier haben wir zum beispiel ronny räumt
den kundus auch schlecht also schon gut
so dann haben wir noch anspielung auf
den bekannten werbeslogan wer hat's
erfunden die deutschen nicht immer für
alles schieben wir deutschen oder in
deutschland ja früher viel gemacht zum
beispiel erst mal mit ja es ist relativ
imposant aber was der bundeswehr
natürlich fehlt um neue mitglieder
anzuwerben das ist sex den sex sells wir
haben keinen vorschlag mädels
[Applaus]
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbole bei uns im neuen studio gefunden
wie laminat die freimaurer staatsführung
ist alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekanntgeben
erst bei so vielen abonnenten auf
youtube also ich würde mich ran halten